[Musica]
ciao ragazzi bentornati a una puntata di
cucina bastata quello di oggi è un
evento irripetibile
ci stiamo avvicinando alla fine di
questa stagione ci stava avvicinando
all'estremo un saluto nei confronti di
questa cucina perché molto molto presto
tutto questo sarà un nuovo set
all'interno del nostro nell'ufficio ed è
proprio in occasione di questo mese del
pride questo mese dell'accettazione
questo mese soprattutto nel quale si
promuove l'amore fra tutti quanti io ho
pensato di far tornare su questo canale
un elemento importante richiesto sotto
tutti quanti i video un elemento che è
stato fondamentale per la crescita di
questo format meraviglioso di cucina un
elemento che oggi vi presenterò per
l'ultima volta dopo tanto tanto tempo
sto parlando del grembiule perché gli
dico a di oltre che questo qui è
l'ultimo video nel quale indosserò
questo meraviglioso stupendo iconico
grembiule di cucina buttata stiamo già
lavorando un nuovo grembiule quindi
state tranquilli col nuovo se
arriveranno un sacco di nuove sorprese
ma per celebrare questi tre anni passati
insieme io dopo un paio di lacrimuccia
tutti quanti abbiamo deciso di separarci
da questo meraviglioso grembiule per
destinarlo a un'iniziativa di
beneficenza per ha messo all'asta
molto probabilmente noi non avremo
quindi preparatevi a qualsiasi tipo di
odore se non e cade riuscirete secondo
me a prendere tutti quanti i residui di
tutte le carbonari di merda che abbiamo
fatto
gli hamburger che abbiamo copiato da
mcdonald e dagli altri fast food
qualsiasi istante di cucina buttata
impresso nelle mutandine di questo
meraviglioso crea in più le nella
scollatura soprattutto il ricavato di
questa asta di beneficenza porterà a dei
fondi che verranno devoluti a la casa
arcobaleno in cui scopo è quello di
accogliere tutte quante le persone della
comunità lgbt che vengono allontanate
dalle loro case e quindi si ritrovano
giovanissime spesso senza un tetto sotto
e poi poter stare sia per il loro
orientamento sessuale che per il loro
orientamento di genere
è un qualcosa che purtroppo avviene è un
qualcosa che a me tocca particolarmente
perché non riesco a immaginare del
privilegio che ho avuto a livello
proprio di affetto familiare come posso
una famiglia allontanare un figlio per
un motivo così stupido detto ciò
iniziamo con la ricetta di oggi è una
recente quella cerebrale sia i
meravigliosi colori di cui è composto il
mondo tutti quanti diversi e tutti
ugualmente validi una ricetta facile e
veloce come facile veloce realtà voler
bene agli altri indipendentemente da
quanto diverse da noi siano e
soprattutto una certa carica di burro e
coloranti partiamo subito quindi con il
rainbow toast per fare il nostro rainbow
tous il nostro rainbow tosta abbiamo
bisogno di pancarrè mozzarella per pizza
mi raccomando se non suda ovunque 100 g
di burro che lo rende un arancio iconico
e posso dirti era giusto però che arriva
al suo momento nel quale non venisse
dimenticato ma anzi venisse celebrato la
scelta avevo smesso di usare in più lì
perché perché siamo entrati all'interno
di una topaia nella quale questo
grembiule non meritava di esistere e
adesso andrà a qualcuno che potrà
utilizzarlo per paris ricette di verne
portafortuna cioè se siete nel dubbio
saprete automaticamente che quando ho
indossato e nero tutto male e mi
raccomando ragazzi se doveste ottenere
questo che in diretta agate mia
all'interno di una stories la quale
avete questo quadro certo e non abbia
motivare che mandiamo il carico dei topi
però magari vedrete qualche piccola
macchia che è rimasta nel tempo ma i
ragazzi sono marche che raccontano una
storia a perfezione fa cacare quello che
andiamo a fare oggi è diversamente
salutare possiamo dirlo perché tutto
colorante praticamente ma l'effetto
finale pazzesco ci stiamo per mangiare
pane e burro colorante
per celebrare il mese del fai
esattamente di vedere come cachi alla
fine
è una ricetta
che non ha proprio delle dosi perfetto
quindi per te esatto una ricetta
anarchica dividiamo la mozzarella in
cinque parti più o meno uguali
mi raccomando ragazzi lavorate in un
piatto molto molto grande o addirittura
in cinque ciottoli e diverse sa meno ma
noi di sporcare perché non c'è
sbattimento alcuno di dovermi metterli a
pulire 5 coloranti diversi e con quasi
ti vedesse rigo tagliani con le forbici
la mostra lo sai che intasca herbert
mariconda che ha mai cucinato nella vita
sua ci fosse da bruno barbieri a dire
sai odio questa cosa verdetto cacchio ci
ha ragione in una voce marco l'ha fatta
mente un'idea il formatore immersione e
quindi quest'anno siamo più veloci
non so dove si nascondesse questi input
nelle cose che hai detto ma sono sicuro
che da qualche parte to qualche momento
mi hai fatto arrivare questa idea
funziona viene addirittura quasi una
pasta
mi raccomando ragazzi quando dovete
passare le dita sul mipim era staccato e
tutto minimo minimo attivate qualcosa
fate ma lì parte tutto sono tra
abbastanza terrorizzante è abbastanza
per arrivare la magia dividiamo di nuovo
in cinque montarozzi diversi severo
sembra un'altra formando iniziano a
mettere qual caso di cane rosso il viola
quindi ci metterò in sé come vorrei
proprio fucsia più rosso
mettiamo poco blu qui blu che come
vorrei un verde più chiaro farò poco blu
e più giallo e infine il giallo giallo
andiamo succede prende con un grande
colore colore è andato la salute al
verde perde vorrei forse un po più di
giallo questa può venire estremamente
bella ma non ci devo mettere secondo me
troppo blu perché caricandola tanto di
blu diventa scurissima guarino rosso e
basta molto molto interessante
e molto bello a questo punto andiamo a
creare le 5 strisce di colore rosso
giallo verde blu viola di mettere più o
meno in parti uguali non credo con tosti
così kaki l'aurora boreale mamiliano
introdotti 6 doveva entrare in quel
periodo
se riesce a contare sono cinque stata
bellissima ma speriamo venga bene lo sai
che sono fiducioso che può andare storto
ribelli che sono stai dicendo tutte cosa
può andare storto strass cordera ovunque
perché troppo formaggio richiamo gesù
burro senza paura il burro serve per
fare quell'effetto french toast capito
per renderlo ancora più dannoso per la
nostra salute poi puoi fare capitano le
cose che lo aprì ci vedi tutto
l'arcobaleno dai l'odore leggero mi sta
uccidendo guglielmo col grembiule e lo
puliamo ci siamo
mamma mia ragazzi non segna
spettacolo vi rendete conto nella mia
manco più fervida immaginazione avrei
mai pensato che sarebbe venuto così bene
lo assaggiamo in onore di questo pride e
di una casa arcobaleno soprattutto
gustoso se sente tanto del colorante
diciamo che non si può parlare dietro ad
essere bello è bello è le calorie di un
singolo boccone non oso immaginare
proprio salire costoso per i miei gusti
più bello e gustoso davvero non si sente
troppo il colorante successo successo
ragazzi siamo arrivati alla fine di
questo video colgo l'occasione in realtà
per ringraziarvi tutti quanti per il
supporto crete è nato a questo format
per tutti questi tre anni per il
supporto enorme che date proprio a me
alla famiglia vi ringrazio spero
vivamente che questo grembiule possa
trovare un nuovo padrone una nuova
padrona un nuovo chrome che possa
trattarlo come merita io vi lascio qui
sotto il link per quella che sarà l'asta
di beneficenza
nel frattempo diamo una buonissima
domenica ci vediamo presto con un altro
video su questo canale
ciao
[Musica]